[Music]
ant-man and the wasp comes out in just a
few short weeks and it is said that they
are going to heavily explore the quantum
realm and with all the leaks that have
come out lately it's been pretty much
confirmed that Avengers 4 will heavily
rely on the quantum realm as well so in
this video we'll go over the question
what exactly is the quantum realm well
dive into where it came from in the
comics compared to the MCU and then
we'll talk about how it can affect
Avengers 4 first things first be sure to
subscribe to my channel for more videos
on Marvel and the MCU and to stay
up-to-date on Avengers 4 the quantum
realm is an alternate dimension and it's
only accessible through subatomic
Shrinking like we saw an ant-man or
through magical or mystical
transportation such as the sling ring
that we saw in Doctor Strange now
obviously these are in the MCU
and in the MCU the quantum realm was
discovered to be accessible by the
scientist dr. Hank Pym dr. Hank Pym
describes the quantum realm in ant-man
by saying it's a reality where all
concepts of time and space become
irrelevant as you shrink for all
eternity dr. Hank Pym has dedicated his
life to researching the quantum realm
ever since his wife Janet Van Dyne got
stuck in the quantum realm when she went
subatomic so that's the quantum realm
and the MCU let's talk about the comics
now the quantum realm in the comics is
actually called the Microverse Marvel
Studios actually can't use the name
Microverse because they don't own the
rights to it more on that a bit
in the comics ant-man and the wasp
actually aren't the first to discover
the quantum realm the Microverse first
appears in Captain America vol 1 number
25 and it was actually Steve Rogers and
Bucky Barnes who entered it then in
Fantastic Four volume 1 number 10 Doctor
Doom is transported to the microfiche
and then he traps the Fantastic Four
there and then finally in Fantastic Four
vol 1 number 16 ant-man shrinks down to
go inside the Microverse and he rescues
the Fantastic Four in the comics the
Microverse is sort of its own universe
and inside that universe it has other
worlds and I actually think that they're
going to explore this a little bit and
ant-man and the wasp so that's the
difference between the quantum realm in
the MCU and the quantum realm /
Microverse
as I mentioned before Marvel Studios
does not own the rights to Microverse so
they needed to change that in the MCU
and they actually brought in a real
quantum physicist to do the job they
brought in dr. Spyros McCulloch is a
quantum physicist and staff researcher
at the California Institute of
Technology dr. McKee Lucas is the one
who coined the term quantum realm and
here's what he had to say about ant-man
and the quantum realm in a blog post in
2015 if someone could go to a place
where the laws of physics as we know
them were not yet formed at a place
where the arrow of time was broken and
the fabric of space was not yet woven
the powers of such a master of the
quantum realm would only be constrained
by their ability to come back to the
same or similar reality from which they
departed all the superheroes of Marvel
and DC Comics combined would stand no
chance against Ant Man with a
malfunctioning regulator pretty powerful
words from an actual quantum physicist
so now that we've talked about what the
quantum realm is how to access it and
its origins in the MCU and the comics
let's talk about how crucial of a role
it's going to play in Avengers 4 I
should note right now that if you
haven't seen infinity war yet you should
have but also they're spoilers coming up
sothe Anas collected all of the Infinity
stones put them in the Infinity Gauntlet
snapped his fingers and wiped out half
of the universe from existence there's
really no way that they can defeat
Thanos as is right now he has the
Infinity Gauntlet still with all of the
Infinity stones and unless he's going to
willingly give it up for some reason
they can't defeat him not to mention we
don't even really know what planet he's
on I know at the end of infinity war
they showed the clip where he's sitting
in his little Hut and it's green fields
but again we don't really know where he
is he has the space stone he could go
anywhere in the universe so really the
only options for the current Avengers
are one get the Infinity Gauntlet from
Thanos and again without him willingly
giving it up good luck to a theory that
I personally came up with myself that I
actually think would kind of work but it
would be it wouldn't be very cinematic
and that is to go back in time and have
Wanda or the
which destroyed the time stone first
that way it cannot be used to bring back
other Infinity stones and then they can
just pray that Thanos doesn't know how
to go back in time without the time
stone I'm sure there is holes in my
theory but on the surface I think it
could work and then there's the third
which seems to be the actual plot of
Avengers 4 and that is to access the
quantum realm to go back in time and to
go into different realities to where the
Avengers can collect the Infinity stones
themselves make their own Infinity
Gauntlet somehow and use it against
Thanos and again thanks to some leaks
that have recently happened this seems
to be confirmed as the plot for Avengers
for both the second and the third theory
rely on time travel and this is why the
quantum realm is so important to
Avengers for time-travel has not been
invented in the MCU yet the only time
travel that we've seen has been because
of the time stone and as I mentioned in
the beginning of the video the quantum
realm is a place where time and space
are irrelevant Ant Man of the wasp is
really going to explore the quantum
realm and I believe that at some point
in the movie
they're going to figure out time travel
they may not perfect it but they're
gonna realize it's possible via the
quantum realm if they don't perfect it I
believe Tony Stark's gonna come into the
picture and then him and dr. Hank Pym
will work together in figuring out how
to make time-travel work and if they
don't I don't think there's any way to
defeat Thanos but again most of this has
already pretty much been confirmed so
you can clearly see just how important
the quantum realm is to Avengers 4 the
Avengers defeating Thanos and bringing
back half of the universe that was wiped
from existence so there's everything you
need to know about the quantum realm
what are your thoughts what do you think
is gonna be shown to us and ant-man and
the wasp and what do you think is gonna
happen in Avengers 4 let me know your
thoughts in the comments below and if
you enjoyed this video please hit that
thumbs up button and of course subscribe
to my channel to stay up to date on
Avengers 4 Ant Man of the WASC all
things Marvel DC & superhero thank you
so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]